alter die kann man echt weit ausfahren
jetzt habe ich sogar schon dass hier ich
habe auch so einen kopf kauder jetzt
kann ich mich ja richtig selber mit
billigen
nein so war das nicht gemeint und was
geht ab und herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video ja natürlich hoffen
natürlich euch jetzt gut
ich habe mich heute hier wieder
hingesetzt also ich muss sagen
eigentlich sollte heute ein ganz anderes
video kommen problem ist gewesen einige
der sachen war nicht da deswegen muss
jetzt umdisponieren weil es für mich am
freitag in den urlaub geht für eine
woche ich bin dieses jahr zum ersten mal
im urlaub
das stimmt so auch nicht youtuber
luxusprobleme das ist jetzt ein bisschen
abgehobene tschuldigung na ja auf jeden
fall machen wir heute nach langer zeit
mal wieder ein paar kostenlose produkte
das habe ich jetzt ein geschoben weil
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich hatte
noch sehr viele und ich habe auch extra
neu bestellt coole sachen eigentlich wir
können aber ganz kurz einmal durchs
kippen also ich werde euch jetzt nicht
jedes produkt zeigen wir packen die
gleich einfach eins nach dem anderen aus
aber ich habe jetzt noch einiges
bestellt und das ist halt alles schon da
ja hier vielleicht mal ein kurzer
überblick ich wette dass hier mal ein
ihr könnt ja so einfach drüber schauen
ich habe keine ahnung also das was ihr
seht sind alles kostenlose sachen und
höre das jetzt nicht mehr warten
eigentlich war das noch mehr oder aber
mir geht es noch weiter
ja ich weiss nicht also dass hier waren
schon im letzten paar drin aber dass
darüber nicht wo war ich beim letzten
mal auch nur ein euro produkte bestellt
habe dann habe ich eigentlich die ganze
dieses messer in der hand das wirkt ein
bisschen brutalen dass wir euch gleich
und für die pakete es ist nur irgendwie
zunehmend schwerer kostenlose sachen zu
finden weil sonst war immer alles
kostenlos gefühlt und jetzt haben wir
ein so habe ich sogar bestellt hier
haben wir noch was
wir haben wir es hier immer was aber
vieles davon kenne ich halt auch schon
aber ich habe wirklich 10 15 minuten
runter gescrollt und
das kostenlos war und ich euch noch
nicht gezeigt haben oder irgendwann mal
bestellt haben wagen kopfball hat
deswegen ja ich denke es wird auf jeden
fall sehr cool wo ist jetzt meine okay
das sind alles sachen die ich jetzt hier
hatte einige sind auch noch in köln muss
ich sagen hier ist ein haar zwischen wir
schieben das man kurz zur seite und
fangen wir jetzt rennt da mal hiermit an
während sich das auspacken würde ich
mich super freuen wenn wir den kanal ab
abonniert
was ist das denn da kann ich mich nicht
daran erinnern dass sich das bestellt
hat heute ausgeht ich bin was ist das
für einer maske was soll das sein also
wo ich konnte nicht kann man es jetzt
sein können was das sein soll
schreibt eure vermutung in die
kommentare die das gros durchaus also
also gespannt auf neue ist halloween
kostüm mein gott ich bin so dumm
ich glaube das ist nur für partner so
ist das also die nase und der mond der
familie jetzt erkannt ich bin wirklich
mal gespannt wie das im schnitt aussieht
ob das jetzt vollgas aussieht also gar
keine ahnung wo es herkommt aber weißt
du okay ich habe ich schon reingeguckt
weil ich so halbwegs große pakete auch
immer auf machen muss um das zuordnen
hinter der kamera liegt nämlich auch
noch einen riesenberg und da auch noch
und ich muss die sachen ja vorher
trennen
okay hier haben wir eine tragbare led
camping hänge licht zelt an den laternen
aha kannst du das
also wir den batterien jetzt muss ich
erst wieder irgendwo batterien suchen
aber das gibt es doch nicht alter jetzt
habe ich zwei batterien noch gefunden
und hier müssen 3
ich blende euch das hier noch mal kurz
ein wie es dann aussieht also ich besorg
nochmal dritte also ich kann sagen
schlecht ist das ding nicht erfüllt
seinen zweck bringst du drauf hat einen
lauf schon hell weil ich bin mal gerade
im dunklen raum gegangen jetzt fast auf
gute helligkeit bisschen dunkler und
jetzt bringt das egal wir lassen uns
davon nicht beirren und machen weiter
was haben wir denn hier okay das
leuchtet schon alltag
kann das sein erst pro ich weiß gar
nicht doch wer von euch kann sich noch
an die ganzen airports videos erinnern
wahrscheinlich vielen die habe ich eher
prozess war das denn an ein produkt mit
dieser idee konnte nicht gefunden werden
die gibt sich mehr leute ich glaube dass
hier ein airport prophet für zehn euro
10 euro habe ich dafür bezahlt und sechs
euro versand also insgesamt 16 euro was
für ein airport projekt sehr günstig war
deswegen habe ich das gestell dabei sind
natürlich nichts mit diesem video zu tun
deswegen china erstmal zur seite wenn es
irgendwo mal rein passt zeige ich euch
die noch mal oder sonst schreibe es in
die kommentare
vielleicht auch über instagram alex wie
abchecken mache weiter mit dem nächsten
produkt das habe ich schon gesehen was
es ist also ich kann es zu ordnen für
mich absolut legal alter ganz krass ist
gut jetzt kommt raus die kann man
echtzeit ausfahren jetzt habe ich sogar
schon dass hier
ich habe auch so einen kopf kauder ace
kann ich mich ja richtig selber
befriedigen nein so war das nicht
gemeint
auf jeden fall wenn es irgendwo im
rücken juckt kammer das ist schon sehr
entspannt man kann sich selber grauen
damit und das ist das ist ja so ein
phänomen
wenn man sich selber kraut ist es so ein
bisschen aber wenn man von jemand
anderem
gekauft wird fühlt sich richtig leisten
und das ist jetzt so ein mittelding
dazwischen aber schon fast
dann ist so jemand anders kauend ich das
mache ich jetzt ich mache jetzt ich muss
euch das zeit immer leute wie nah ist ja
mit der koordination ist das nämlich so
gut aber es ist schon gut also dafür
daumen nach oben
warum auch immer ich weiß es nicht war
das ist echt sehr sehr nice nächstes
produkt was haben wir denn hier
das ist eine digital sky professional
mini als wenn das kostenlos war
doch es kann aber sein leute ich weiß
was es ist eine taschen waage
die hat sogar dass ich dachte jetzt habe
ich schon wieder das problem mit den
batterien aber wir haben ja zwei
batterien und die passen genau hier ein
ja der erfindet bitten was du drei
batterien rein müssen die halter nicht
okay dann kann man das aufmachen und
okay leute ihr könnt das sehen gerade
zeigt die mini waage 0 kilo an
jetzt stelle ich mich mal drauf milchbar
sanitär kaputt die ist ja nicht
versuchen für so viele leute wie mich
gemacht mich würde echt mal
interessieren wie ich werde dieses
cuttermesser hier ist link war das
nochmal drauf 69,2 gramm ich hatte
eigentlich gedacht dass liegt 100 kommt
noch eine idee iphone elf wie schwer ist
ein iphone 11 legen was man drauf hat
also ich glaube er geht nur bis 100
gramm oder so bis 200 gramm können wir
das kleine paket liegt sechs gramm also
ich kann sondern minima gehalt überhaupt
nichts anfangen
den passenden gerufen wird sowas
bestimmt viel verwendet im labor oder so
deswegen ja wirklich mal zur seite
okay leute kommen wir zum nächsten
produkt und das ist folgendes habe ich
mir bestellt
manchmal ist halt wirklich auch eine
leuchte keinen plan mann
ich finde das nicht in meine bestellung
ich glaube die kommen weil ich schon so
viel bestellt habe irgendwie darauf
durcheinander
ich weiß nicht ob er das video gesehen
habe mit den amazon sachen ich habe da
mal ein bisschen hinterher telefoniert
weil mich das schon gewundert hat weil
ich schon wieder jetzt drei pakete
bekommen ab und selbst die amazon
mitarbeiterin am telefon konnte mir das
nicht genau erklären sie meinte es ist
sehr wahrscheinlich dass das schenkungen
sind von irgendwo und was das jetzt ist
ich weiß es nicht man es sieht aus wie
ein schwamm
aber dafür ist es eigentlich dass du
oder hast du vielleicht zum kinder fragt
mich nicht wenn ihr das irgendwo schon
mal gesehen hat ich schreibe es in die
kommentare und ich muss sagen ich bin
ein bisschen deprimiert weil ich
eigentlich noch ein zwei coole sachen
dabei hatte die aber hier nicht bei sind
und ich weiß jetzt gar nicht was das
hier ist ja okay das könnte jetzt wieder
ganz interessant werden das ist ein
gerät mit dem kannst du oder sieht aber
gefährlich aus hier also gut verarbeitet
ist sagt nicht wir müssen jetzt wieder
batterien
lass mich raten die sind zu klein leute
ich war einkaufen und habe gerade
batterien gekauft damit ich jetzt hier
weitermachen kann
das ist so schlecht verarbeitet hier
nicht kann man sich nicht vorstellen
es riecht auch ein bisschen komisch okay
aber es ist an hoffe ich mal okay das
ist jetzt bisschen blöd wir haben keine
beschreibung doch beschreibung ist dabei
auf der verpackung kann ich leider nicht
mehr stehen
nur da tut sich eben wie gar nichts als
wenn das jetzt zu gehen
solche gut es ist wirklich zu das ist ja
wirklich geniale jetzt mal was lockt man
hierzu jetzt ja doch jetzt regt das ist
gefallen
jetzt ist es wieder zu geiles teil man
das behalte ich auf jeden fall auch wenn
ich nicht weiß es ja an sich jetzt die
ganze zeit an
man kann das hier so locken jetzt ist es
wichtig weiß nicht ich nehmen
vorsichtshalber die batterien mal wieder
raus aber damit bin ich zufrieden
perfekt okay dann macht man noch weiter
ich weiß was es ist drogendealer beutel
hier kannst du dann so groß und so ein
tun oder und drogen safe wofür soll es
sonst sein wo war damit werde ich reich
alter jetzt werd ich mal ein bisschen
mein leben müssen leute ab jetzt gibt es
bei mir den besten start ein kleiner
spaß
aber für so was ist das ja
wahrscheinlich okay vergessen wir
nächstes produkt was haben wir denn
jetzt noch goldkette leute ich weiß was
das ist das ist so ein band das kannst
du dir irgendwie haltet euch fest das
hier ist ein anti schnarch band also was
kann man sich irgendwie so über den kopf
legen wir auf diesem foto hier und
schneidet dann nicht mehr weil das
magneten hat ich glaube es ist an der
zeit dieses video zu beenden
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen abonniert
sehr gern den kanal für weitere
verrückte videos die nächsten unboxing
es werden wieder echt nice also dass im
coole sachen dabei würde mich super
freund jack die letzten videos ab und an
die fragen was mit der ps4 und wer die
kriegt das löse ich im nächsten wie
frischmilch products video auf also noch
nicht hier bisschen geduld bitte noch
das war's doch nach oben 13